oh and I surprised how long has it going
Craig Ferguson yes right mike rizzo
Krista Stefano come in I think okay
Connie how are you
we're coming in it is perfect hi Craig
are you on right now we are all relying
right now oh I love this show we're just
talking about just talking about we talk
about bombing and and opening for
somebody more famous in the crowd
doesn't want to see you and they want to
see the person that you are I don't
think I arrived just as the right it is
the worst when you work at material do
you go up with a with a notebook and
just start we will up comfortably and
bomb if you get work on stuff now I I go
to I go to the Ice House in Pasadena or
what I tend to do these days is you know
the the works in Denver downtown LA yeah
that's a great room right so what I do
is I make a deal with them and I
announce edges new material show and so
it's gonna be rough but I write it as
much as like I write over anything and I
learn bit and then I go up and do an
hour and how much ticket we shall take
is cheaper no behavior so they're more
expensive it's do it again and see the
process they're [ __ ] luckier there
all right fair enough yeah I think that
Club you can get away with that because
that Club is it's very it's a real bit
of proper American comedy club it's like
downtown it's in a basement they're
serving chicken fingers it's like it's
it's old-school like those guys going up
there with piano key ties on it yeah
he's rolled up its yeah jeans yeah the
1988 and he didn't problem yeah yeah
it's all happening like that so I kind
of found that's what I do I just like I
like going up there and just kind of get
it done and then I feel I don't know
about you guys if I have an hour ready
like e.coli now it's probably like an
hour and 15 and 20 if I have that say I
feel okay if I don't have an hour ready
to go I feel like I mean I could get in
trouble like I'm gonna lose all my money
and live on the streets what so Chris
was just saying that yeah I was saying
that um you know I I'm gonna do an hour
special this year and I was talking to
Colin Quinn about it just trying to get
some advice and he was like man if you
don't have
if you don't have a whole second hour I
wouldn't do the first hour because the
only people going to come see you the
people come the people see the hour
going to come see you it's in the
stand-up Club and if you're doing the
same hour they're gonna be like what the
[ __ ] yeah you saw I had I didn't think
about it that way yeah I know you yeah
he's absolutely right you get away with
it once
like if you do the same material to the
same crowd one time they won't come to
you again
well they really come a couple lines you
can get away with or a bit or two that
they like to hear
McCallum is also just trying to show off
with years hours to burn that's also
college only two and a half hours as 100
is if it's a summer you're going to have
your summer I want to shut up going to
do comedy eight years only got an hour
and a half with a pundit on write more :
does write a lot it's your second name
yeah he's actually very disciplined it
really bothers me yeah yeah I think
that's not fair
and it's frightening to the younger
comedian I think like it's okay you'll
be fine just also you know the thing I
hate to use this source because it's
unfashionable and comedy circles the one
thing Lana told me that really works
which is like they don't know the
[ __ ] script they're they just keep
[ __ ] talking like so if you you know
if you go there you go for go a bit they
don't [ __ ] know you forgot a bit yes
keep going it was funny talking is this
funny to our people I forget that lana
was a great comment yeah he wasn't one
of the most Pro like a working standard
I head liners in the country like yeah I
was just on Howard Anita and Howard was
talking about he used to seal a know
like Letterman and him would go and
watch Lane him because he was the guy to
go and see I like back in the day that
they would go and watch Lana do stand-up
oh okay you know that was like that was
the aspirational stand-up comedian was
Jay he was the Louie CK the you know the
Dave Chappelle of the time
yeah people forget that too scary though
that it goes from like being like you're
the moat like you said fashionable guy
comedians love you and now like every
young comedian you're supposed to hate
Leno he's supposed to be a hacker
because he was successful it like a
committees are gonna hate anyone then
once you get out of the the box and you
start doing Billy don't worry this is an
advantage to being hated enough people
know you were someone we're going to hit
your
you know you've made it yeah what
everybody hates you well it does a
little bit I mean no I mean those guys
who are just like do you watch that
Chappelle special yeah
I did not i watch the flower so I hear
they're amazing I like to sec I mean I
laughed at both of them but the second
one was great you know weirdly I thought
the first one was the one was I yeah
yeah I was the first one and I was like
wait is he is he resin what the what the
[ __ ] is he gonna see happen and then I
get like to the end of it and he
finishes up with this bet that ties the
whole thing in yeah yeah hue month it
was like at the end of the sixth sense I
was like [ __ ] I didn't even see
a comment there telling you that's what
Sam tell me I had a first special we're
all like you start over here and then
the middle goes back to the beginning
and it goes on to something totally
different like did he remember that he
set this up and then I was back at the
end it's really both I didn't see the
second guy yeah the [ __ ] Chappelle
does even have another hour to go that's
right he's a stack of hours he really is
[ __ ] amazing it's incredible and the
the the attitude on stage that kind of
way of being is like I never been that
cool on my own after having sex right he
has that ability just to talk and he's
just a casual interesting guy and I've
seen at the cellar enough times where
he's but he almost feels like no
pressure to be funny and he just is
funny yeah and he just happens to be
[ __ ] hilarious and interesting
combination 30 years he said he's been
doing stand-up and then even on his
special he's like asking the crowd if
you have a cigarette people are like
throwing cigarette to the stage he's
just picking them up smoking them
sitting on this like nothing like no
pressure at all just beautiful yeah it's
kind of great I love that I see see I
think when I remember it start known as
a stand-up of his backstage that was in
Adelaide Australia
and it was me and a stand-up comedian
cold-air need Engel under an Aboriginal
stand-up comedian coat Arry dangle he's
funny and we're both walking back to the
he's from the outback in Australia and
I'm from Scotland were both pacing
backstage and get an adrenal and then he
said to me you know mate I ask myself
what are we doing this for
what do you mean like stand-up we might
know this [ __ ] pacing backstage
nobody gets to see this I'm not gonna do
it anymore and what you're [ __ ] right
yeah you know that actually that all
that stuff pumping yourself up yeah
that's the officer
you see you know rookie stand-ups do all
the time pop yourself up get ready get
ready get ready but for man it should be
the other way adrenaline is not your
friend
you know adrenaline is your enemy in
this situation you should be like
Hannibal Lecter when he you know when he
bites that many bites the nurses zero
for sure that it also doesn't change
yeah yeah like that's how you should be
going out there serial killer [ __ ]
instead of my sucking my dick between my
legs so good I think for the more mature
stand-up tucking your dick between yeah
cuz it's gonna happen anyway you know as
you age your dick just it's a nice
opening oh I danced my way up Ryan Cross
yeah they're getting pumped up you do
stuff Barry Katz told me that [ __ ]
years ago we were talking to my manager
and I would always get myself in this
headspace and he goes you know someday
you're gonna be able just to walk in and
walk on and be funny and he was right
like you don't have to get yourself
place yeah it's a lip it's a real it's a
real wrong turn for for young stand-ups
I think that and the guitar yeah you
know like these oh man don't take the
guitar unless you do a mr. original song
I've heard you every time I think that
you all of a sudden see a guitar acting
like a [ __ ] like Stephen Lynch writes
original music yeah it writes real music
and god damn he's good like his stuff is
genuinely funny it once in a while
you'll find one who's like I think I've
been troll acquits one out of twenty but
every now and again like to mention can
do it with the piano and stuff like that
but it's every now and again you see but
most times you see guitar nearing a [ __ ]
here we go yeah because I had the guitar
did you really
or just saw parody yeah it was that
Scottish folk songs remember I was
working in school of course so uh yeah I
the guitar in the comedy jacket and oh
my god it was bad I look like a [ __ ]
clown did you really there was one of
your songs what was the name of it I
don't want to talk about that that's not
fair I was just a name alright Scotland
who cook I and the Sheep song I sang a
song about sheep [ __ ] did you really
it's very popular there I've heard yeah
yeah back then you know now it's all
changed the European Union
so I you did a song on cheap talk you
keep a pile on crazy though
well you know they hadn't heard it
before it was the thing please don't
make me talk about the cheap [ __ ] so
I love it yeah you're getting to know
why I'm getting read about is the idea
because like when you started stand-up
not like you think about your airlie box
and horrible oh my can feel my buttocks
clench and my ass is so old know that
the idea that it cleanses yeah it can
ever it's unbelievable I'm actually
going to go out and meet a friend
because but it's no it's kind of oh god
it makes my flesh crawl
yeah weird how exposing old can we talk
I was in Judy Kim and Chris to basically
play doing it this morning like the top
of the show we were playing my old stuff
and all stuff that Travis did and it was
just like I hated myself I hated
everybody in the room like I was like
how did I get in this hole why if there
no way out she's like it's oddly
exposing because we meant it like yeah
it is no way to deny the sincerity
behind it like if it wasn't done as a
group to be like alright but like um I
meant it and they know that was meant to
be good
dead serious was that too many bad tapes
yourself and when you started and uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah well when I was when
I was a fourteen I don't know if I have
to tape myself tape when I was 14 you
know the Backstreet Boys and NSYNC were
like a big deal so me and my friends
tried to make a boy band and and we
taped ourselves like with you know
original songs and dancing it was
[ __ ] but it was a little job right it
wasn't like I'm not legit try we tried
to send it into you know I don't know
somebody knew some NAMBLA there is a
limit Jeff come on no way we're sending
it into a suggest yeah yeah that's
that's that's it I my stand-up was you
know you serve the music do you think I
think I did I love my parents definitely
has it yeah we used to hear that Tim I'd
love to hear the team I was just
probably better than you think I better
is a hit in there I don't think that it
is idea there's nowhere I don't know did
you said you sing no so fight you think
you could be this think I don't know it
just look like an easy way to cook
girl this is my faction that is a
totally legitimate way for a young
stand-up to start because you ever
really go any of this other than I the
only reason I going to do in stand-up
with the meat girls and get you know
being a profession that was tolerant of
active alcoholism that's a great
combination you know you meet girls you
get drunk you don't work in the morning
what did you do before it yeah I was a
drummer in band oh you play musical guys
a similar type of you setup but you do
have to keep tempo and like you know
stand up you can be pretty drunk and
still get through it
sure yeah I mean it's not great but you
can get through it what kind of music
was it it's punk rock bass oh wow okay
and were you guys would we guys good no
no but you didn't have to be good during
punk rock I don't like everybody was in
a band during punk rock everybody liked
you it was like when you were doing boy
bands everybody in a play saying yeah
you know everybody was in a bad you
weren't in a band you weren't
participating right like me I was
everywhere yeah and and so it kind of
that's how I dressed it didn't doing
stand-up because one of the guys I was
in a band work was a huge fan of
American stand-up comics he had like
Richard Pryor albums and Steve Martin
albums and stuff that I never heard any
of these guys Bill Cosby album sure you
know and you see that bit and Chappell
thing we did cause because yeah yeah
[ __ ] genius yeah I mean it's
confusingly good like wait a minute I
have to watch I again you [ __ ] my
brain oh it's another one no like gets
there at the end yeah yeah yeah oh my
god but um so I kind of drifted into it
through being in bands that's that's
what brought me in it was never it was
never I learned to love stand-up after I
started doing it I wasn't a fan of it I
really thought about it I started
watching Spanish I was like a punk rock
singer and I was watching old GG Allin
Siddhartha you know talking about
combining music with some kind of a
weird is a pretty good musician right no
it was like not the best oh not the best
music no but it was fun to watch
yeah the tolerance range for a bad
musicianship and punk was good because
it wasn't really about music I mean it
was about music and the stuff that
lasted was music but it wasn't it was
all about attitude and fashion and
rebellion and
it was it was kind of a movement right
like knowing of the way that [ __ ]
[ __ ] on Twitter as a movement was the
hashtag movement it was a [ __ ]
movement yeah and it was a change you
know in in art and how are in fashion
and performance and everything was
viewed so it kind of it's through a lot
of people forward in a lot of different
eclectic ways why do you think like like
the the the Sex Pistols they were never
particularly great at their instruments
you know and I mean they were strippers
manure they said like you said couldn't
play the bass that well it couldn't play
for [ __ ] but Jonesy the guitar hey Jones
yeah yeah Jonesy is an excellent
guitarist I mean technically the like
finger wise he's not your wolves but
that sound that he created you don't
know I don't know how anybody got that
he still works using that sound and then
cookie the drummer is really good so you
got a really good guitarist and really
good also immedi was just said may they
felt he couldn't play at all but you
know Matlock he was in the band before
said he could play you know and then you
know Lydon is is what he is yeah he's
like a force of nature
yeah he just complimented Trump people
are [ __ ] freaking out because he just
sided with Trump and city's lovely like
the working-class have spoken and I've
heard them how is that yeah that's not
that surprising it is [ __ ] every but
everybody hates Trump so why would he
also hate crime well yeah that's right
that way but I would never have seen him
coming without opinion that's completely
shocking that he said that I think
that's why he said you might be right
enjoy letting go yeah there's been
completely shocking things is kind of
his thing
have you interviewed him yes I am we've
had him on a couple times once with uh
with Anthony I think once after he's a
really fascinating yeah he's a smart guy
and and and tripod and weird and then
odd mind and likes to say things that
annoys people so after all do you like
having a daily gig like after being in
bands and comedy like a TV show becomes
a daily gig and you've got the daily gig
now here doing the radio show yeah like
the radio show is different though and
like the TV gig is actually that's
that's kind of relentless and not as
much fun this is like we walked in here
today there was no plan so there's no
like I didn't talk to 25 publicists and
write a lot of business going on it's
just like no I like
yeah I'll be there in 10 minutes and you
just walk in and do the show it's a very
different vibe I could send her tennis
Craig has to go I didn't know that
Travis might might Mike for sometimes
I'm not picking you up I'm sure that's
my fault I apologize but now we didn't
know you had to go so I go to think but
the but I wanted to come say hi and
thank you for being on the show last
night
it was really fun you were awesome thank
you very much and I remain a fine good
luck with your special young man you
don't play the guitar all right and you
know you don't have to have a whole hour
Rago Collins being a little King
Kalakaua showing off gonna have a new 90
come on Colin a little tough on ya we
take a quick break you take a leak and
come right back and wrap up the show
break yet we gotta take one more nice
Craig for coming in and Christian
hanging that's just cool